Hi, it's f*** like 1
I've already done more to do Anna also
needs audios/sell where I'm
sure there's no one they can't stand is
here o
You've already watched Free Press Hotel
and apprehend a weapon opposite Lurdinha
from our  Sally who was the conciliator
commissione she introduces adds
program of ink from Aparecida to people
already Portuguese cigar and there cousin Minister
Antonio to wear ungrateful lady
president answer her standing in your
presence and in the water and I will give rain and
Xororó Hello cousin the minister Costa Dragon
What's up
What
's up Mr President of the
European Parliament Madam President of the
European Commission what time and gentlemen
chairmen of the political groups
Commissioners ladies and gentlemen
company covid-19 Europe
crisis your biggest post-war challenge  war
and families were distorted with the
loss of nearly a million
human lives and we were dragged into a
devastating economic and social crisis
across the 27  member states
and around constitutes access for all
European citizens against
financial stability and
Croatian presidencies And in the European response to
this dramatic crisis
the start of the vaccination process AND the
approval of the multiannual financial
framework and the problem opens a door
to hope
and  the presidency of the Council at the time
of five research in recent months
as a motto to drive for a
Just and digital recovery main priorities
Portuguese Economic recovery the
social development of the World Cup open to the
world the first condition of recovery
indispensable vaccination together to listen and
all the potential of the uterus
o  international for the eradication of the
pandemic on a global scale whether in our
shipments or in the African continent
or in Latin America
and in parallel we have economic
and social cooperation the new and at least with a
successful application of
own resources regulations care and
Recovery and resilience may come  to
be approved by  r what for us to overcome this
crisis remains jointly throughout the
union
and the new GNA portal of the mind the
determination of time problems and
Hello gentlemen that the fight is
all to discover what we have and continue
to have ahead of us because European cooperation
must be based  -if we are driving
the transition to the climate and digital transition
we are in a health emergency
but the luxury of wasting more European time
approving how we are ready to
work with you in the body as
soon as possible is really decisive for us to be able to
fulfill our commitment to achieve
neutrality  carbonica 2050
is, but this digital one day a troop on the
Front Line in this particular sense
mission presented here for the protection and
democratic sovereignty and for, in short,
the recovery cannot be limited to
responding to the needs of the present
contest the conjuncture the recovery and
[Music  ]
is more than before the crisis President
ladies and gentlemen
social change
is but  small and medium
-sized companies and European workers are very concerned about
companies Or not being able to accompany
workers in the future of work at their
own workplace from new
forms of work and the virtualization of
social rights hard
won over the years therefore in line with
the report  of the European Parliament a
strong social Europe for transitions
our second question how to specify the
social pillar of the European Union based
[Music]
the digital climate traditions
in New Skin situations traditions education
social protection Porto Social Security
editions United States the main
objective of this first  in the practical oven
their
and proclaimed in 2017 in gothenburg here
from losing to saying i don't know but
food number buys inequalities
in populism
and finally our third to the world
[Music]
of the supply of goods by third parties
real from part 16 therefore we have the
commercial strategy but that cannot
mean n  nh one of the companies in
and lastly was tragic means
as a global player and proud of the partnerships
of Vizinhança Sul EA the
strategic partnership with the African continent
and our transatlantic relations
current United and the United States of
America and on this day when the president will take office
from the dem I cannot fail to
direct the votes for the greatest successes of
his mandate and the aforementioned need for us to
carry out actions United States and we also do not
forget that I am
always being the European Union
's main strategic next brand in the
world and India is that we live  a
summit of the European Union and India also
in the city of Porto focused on
cooperation on digital commerce
knowledge pharmaceutical products
patience multipurpose space the word
on the world of navigation Fields of the
different existing possibilities as
long as it manages to survive and
continue to maintain
the appropriate balance between its
internal and external dimensions be
legal emigration P  resident ladies and
gentlemen it is time to act in
the vaccination process it is time for
comparisons that sleep social it is time to
act to develop social it is time for
strategic autonomy of a Union open to the
world but it is also time to direct towards the
future of Europe and therefore  we need
the conference on the future of europe
as a future doors with me
is
the world least ever while
presidency of the council
fan number and gentlemen let me
conclude were the values ​​europe
was world freedom security and
peace and prosperity after  four years of
dictatorship and discipline even for that reason it is a
necessary condition for the European power
and it is not
the cost of course in this area the wires but
at work registration in Parliament by the
council I believe that we are now
all better prepared to overcome
this pandemic we overcome the teeth and
build  together this is for the best
that's why we assumed the presidency with the
motto very clear  time to come for a
fair green and digital recovery
Thank you all
a serious accident from the Life
Andthen
the call madam risidon ferro with
my girl to be Antônio we took
Mc Orelha due to time small people
privileges like 17 do not go there Nepal
visiting  Lisbon in
the debts of the red UN and of the new year
of pa and having an idea what was discussed in the period
between politics that government in hand was
badmouthing software and said that I don't have
any receive the vote hospitality
miramez issuer headquarters building in the period
of drugs  it's difficult on the channel socials it's hard to
prioritize
the conception of the world to say demographic and
technological video channel capacitai by
John looking for an easy crochet juice
and Division 1 it
's better not passion tired there's no
where oxford simple there's very ugly
in this call it  and so chapatex has no
Souvenir has ordered this work hard
Enduro effect share them Will not lose
out this is a One Direction Rose art
names that Make  Up our Solution Market
Economy
a Battle Expert stations have not
challenge society and Economy have
strong Hold a place on We Heart It is
not really Flex animal Speed ​​Sky love
transformations We report on am in that
Green I hear WhatsApp from the Solution book
shows solidarity between the Generations
o  book than from here bear from our
Partners to shake Herbalife this many
years that I do not see in this protection of
fourteen
the academy today is this from the two Next
Generation you we have also center and
break From This Crisis to get Hold On
to care Shop program WinRAR  ground is not
very much support and workers in this
Hot prove at night Bio and general if you
can samples and Flowers and team member
State of the European Union beat
Matsumoto
o Fabrício Boy we update our Industry is
switched to make show we can Create
Create Jobs  and of and Miguel micos da
Gringa will be with you i love Survive and
better can forward To The Summer
Soul Chamber And pollution and Maybe we
can  send your message along the South of
Paris with Fried onions with And You
Only Once and you exciting things I want
to Thank you thank you for your little
friend your support on
and remember
whether or not you open mihari also depends
on Fame and page  on the vaccines Fred
trailers AIDS has United at seven on it
was The Best Choice Of His best and
worst of the first Country in the world
Where vaccination and a Higher
percentage of the option of member
States are on that list and Hold On
I call you  so I'm going to the recipe for
even started on
Hi, it's chubby camera player It came
from Bros polio a vaccine and the world
blue not married there's almost top to
be free William sweets before that changes
Naf today the year at level 1
just waiting for Honey  board
I wish for time to Star in da front Line
workers to Box To stamp out Loud it
is still necessary that I move this Pro
pausem You vaccine
sherin McMissile Facebook vaccines there direction World
of switching with your love One
Direc  tion to low and middle-income
countries and Solution team work has
already proven lunch Foot Beauty and
love is a force to be Partners in his
last vow and we need to show the same
lyrics when it comes to vaccine in
E then not Samuel howe can  talk about
Share In vaccines web Where not of
vaccination of Souls all is more Who
leaves this not only a matter of
solidarity and Only call me when you get
this Stuff All round 3 free Fire Economy
is rising Power supply chain at outward
or political credibility and  Friends the
show If everything is legs then SAS and
this would not be Forgotten Battles or
owners or I say amendments beat the phone very
different reasons that Europe must be on
the right Side of spreadsheets and now
this House building the same Way
Andthere it
is or  it's not a problem si99 King Tiger on
Hi guys are sneezing about
talking like
we'll see yes I live down here
no yes or no yes or no
the way it wouldn't be as soon as possible
is if I managed to  the boss she
tells me see you in the slipper to see it doesn't really go
yes it's been a while and Sofia's clothes if
today's contrast we see today I don't
even care I'm already going down to
capable professionals this is where they
sell to the variants  Honda Civic SI Hatch
gray favor of the sphere obsidians edukof
were to come Robson
is this indie a Race against time
and diurnos limits to Speed ​​Up The genome
Sequence only one member State of the year
for Santa Rosa stumbles app
thoughts and say where the tooth is
Fiber properties  of the versions would
have shown New ones with and stay' up to
five percent of the last but one two
three four Used
oh my love poems about Seven or single
market' da Mercedes Classe A
o blanka loja boars in the institution
Max no sense in
the design of the marketing
targets Andressa swimming out to
Crazy  if
presidency launching as to make up
together we will overcome and Thank u
Oi Graciane free in Presidente
answer just because I love the leader of the group
and politician President Heber ruler there
talks
a good TVI desk New can here
different EA bomb in the corner Kms of
coast  kuty have your mainly
back that stipulates then no rowing boat
in United Europe scores type Now And
lift Stupid and European Union is not to
Lose anything but I'm in love and have
in the history of Portugal In A Tin can
stop US what you  looking Beyond The
Horizon your looking for a new songs One
free download and 1 and Spirit exeqte
Waldir o principal do Espírito fone
Sport MP3 FM
the material to connect the invitation system
down here Where it is there anyway,
you can simulate it